DYLAN THOMAS: Hello and welcome
to another episode of What
In the World.
This is a regular show where
enterprise Geo Googlers look
at something interesting
in the enterprise products.
My name's Dylan Thomas.
I'm a maps community manager.
And joining me
today is Alan Poole.
ALAN POOLE: Hello.
DYLAN THOMAS: Alan
helps customers
get products deployed
in production.
And so what we wanted to
talk with Alan about today
was sort of a second installment
of Google Maps Engine
connectors.
So on our last episode, we talk
to Ujaval Gandhi about the QGIS
connector he had written
to allow the QGIS desktop
product to connect with Google
Maps Engine for use there.
And what Alan has done is
actually take that same concept
and applied it to ArcGIS, the
commercial desktop GIS product.
So, can you just tell
us briefly before we
look at the demo what the
impetus was behind that?
ALAN POOLE: Sure.
We developed these connectors
for QGIS and ArcGIS
desktop to make it very simple
to sign in if you are a Google
user, as well as find a
map and view it inside
of these desktop tools.
So we want it to be dead
simple for an end user
to view their published
Google Maps Engine maps.
And the primary reason for
building these connectors
is to allow the desktop tools
to securely talk with the Google
Cloud and allow you to sign
in with your credentials.
So the Google Maps Engine
connector for ArcGIS desktop
is available for free.
And it is available to anyone
on the arcgis.com gallery.
So if you go to arcgis.com
and you search for Google Maps
Engine connector and
you click on Tools
and you show our
chairs desktop content,
our tools will show up as well.
So the Google Maps Engine
connector for ArcGIS desktop
will show in the search results.
And it's as simple as
clicking the open link
to download it and install
it in your Arc map instance.
DYLAN THOMAS: So for
any ArcGIS desktop user,
this is just a no-brainer.
This is how they do it.
There's no special
thing going on.
ALAN POOLE: No special thing
going on with these tools.
It's built using the
ESRI add-in framework.
So these are just
like any other add-in
that you would add to ArcMap.
So I'm going to launch
ArcMap to open ArcMap 10.2.
And we'll give it a
few seconds to load.
So this is a standard ArcMap.
And what you see is the
Google Maps Engine connector
for ArcMap tool bar
that is available.
If you don't see
the toolbar, you
can right click
on the tool area,
and it's available to turn
on if you don't see it.
And you'll note that the
tool bar that's available.
None of the buttons
are enabled by default.
So the first step with
the connector for ArcMap
is you need to sign in
with your Google account.
And any Google
account will work.
So the first button lets
you sign in or sign out
of your Google account.
So I'm going to click
the Sign In button.
And since I've already signed in
with my demonstration account,
my name is remembered.
But you could sign in with some
Gmail account or some Google
apps account as well.
I'm going to sign in and
authenticate with my Alan Poole
at altostrat.com account.
The second step is you need
to authorize the connector
to access your Google
Maps Engine data.
So I'm going to click accept.
And you'll note that the
Find button becomes active.
So once you're signed in, you're
able to find Google Maps Engine
maps in any maps engine account.
So I'm going to click
on the Find button.
And the dialogue
pops up and lets
you find any published
map that is available.
And these are the
same maps that we
showed last week
with Ujaval in QGIS.
They're also available to
view here inside of ArcGIS.
So I'm going to click on
the "Earth at Night" map
that he showed last week.
And the ArcGIS
connector communicates
with Google Maps Engine
and automatically ads
a WMS layer of all the layers
inside of your published map.
So if you have a Google Maps
Engine map with vector data
or raster data, those layers are
available in one single click.
So I'm going to turn
on these WMS layers.
And you can see this is the
world at night as published
by NASA.
And there is a
secondary layer that's
added with kind of
ancillary metadata
about your Google
Maps Engine map.
So let me add a
Google Maps engine
map that contains
vector data as well.
So to do that, I'm going to
change the projection of my map
to Web Mercator to align
with the Google Maps Engine
projections.
Now if I go back to
the search dialogue,
I published some
census data as well.
So there are some census
data for San Francisco.
So if I add this census map and
I turn on the sensors census
WMS layers, you'll see that
in the San Francisco area,
there is some road
data as well as
some congressional
boundaries as well.
DYLAN THOMAS: And
you can style this.
This is something that you can
style ArcGIS to some extent,
right?
ALAN POOLE: So these are
just a standard WMS layers.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK, so
they are pre-styled.
ALAN POOLE: They're pre-styled
by the map publisher
inside of Maps engine.
The connectors work with
both raster layers and vector
layers.
And if you have Google
Maps engine maps with one
to many layers, that
works fine as well.
So let me demonstrate
the next piece
of functionality in the map.
So that's all search and kind
of visualization of your maps.
But if I have some local
data that I want to upload,
the Google Maps engine connector
allows you to do that as well.
So I'm going to add a raster
layer and a shapefile that's
locally available
in my repository.
But this would work if
you had an enterprise Geo
databases like an Oracle
spatial or a file Geo database.
All that would work as well.
DYLAN THOMAS: So it's
basically anything
that the ArcGIS recognizes as a
feature class layer or a raster
layer is going to be
fair game to upload.
ALAN POOLE: Exactly.
Any native format that
is supported by ArcMap.
DYLAN THOMAS: Right.
ALAN POOLE: And if
you add a layer,
you'll note that the interact
button becomes active,
and you can actually
interactively upload this data
to your Google Maps
Engine account.
So I'm going to
select the earth TIFF
image that I've
added to my ArcMap.
And you'll note that the
Upload button becomes active.
So I'm going to click on Upload
to Google Maps Engine which
will pop up a dialogue.
And you're asked to fill
in a couple of attributes
about this upload
before you do so.
So the first step is to select
a Google Maps engine an account
that you have access to.
I'm going to click
on altostrat demo.
You have to name this asset, so
I'm going to call it WSI earth,
give it a description, TIFF
image of the entire world,
and give it a tag,
so earth image.
And then the next
two are required,
and they have to exist first.
So you need to
have an access list
that you're going
to upload this to.
So I'm going to call
this connector editors
and give it an attribution,
which we'll call it ESRI.
So the connector
editors are the group
of people that will have
access to this image
once it's uploaded.
So I'm going to click
on Upload files button.
In the Google Maps Engine
connector for ArcGIS
desktop is asking ArcMap
to convert this file
to a standard format that can
be uploaded to the Google Maps
Engine API.
So if it's in some strange file
format that ArcMap understands,
we will ask ArcMap to convert it
to something that is supported.
And once it's
converted, we'll upload
those files your Google
Maps Engine account.
DYLAN THOMAS: That's
what's happening now.
ALAN POOLE: That's what's
happening right now.
DYLAN THOMAS: So in
terms of the API,
we did a little bit of the
meta data work preparation
to fill out your form
now you're doing a post
using basically the new file
upload or asset creation
endpoint.
ALAN POOLE: Exactly.
So first step was just to
request through the mass engine
API a new asset and
then posting each file
to the Maps Engine API.
And the last step
is it opens it up
in the map publishers interface
inside of Google Maps Engine.
You can see it's
already starting
to process for the map editor.
DYLAN THOMAS: So I think
that sort of rounded out
the workflow that we
wanted to share, right?
Which is just simple
access through
unauthorized authenticated
connection [INAUDIBLE],
and the second one is being
able to actually push data
into Maps engine, sort of,
like you said, publish once
for you anywhere.
The second interesting thing
we just want to cover briefly,
I guess, is that this is, in
fact, and open source project
just like the QGIS one is.
And it was written by
yourself up to this point.
I was wondering if
you could tell us
a little bit about that.
Are you accepting pool requests?
How do you see this
growing from here?
ALAN POOLE: The Google Apps
Engine code for the ArcMap
portion is written in
Microsoft.net C# which we think
is very important for a
lot of GIS professionals.
So the code is on the Google
Maps GitHub repository.
So any person can take this code
as reference, or take this code
and add to it.
We are accepting contributions,
but we will take them closely,
kind of guarded,
and we'll add them
to the Google-controlled
compiled version that's
on ArcGIS.com.
So anyone is welcome
to participate
in the open-source project.
And if you're suggestions are
worth putting into the Google
compiled version, we're
willing to do that as well.
DYLAN THOMAS: So the
version that someone,
anyone would download with
no knowledge of the code,
no knowledge of
the API, they just
want to download it to
work with my Maps Engine.
That's going to be something
that we will build, compile
and make sure is on ArcGIS.com.
And if anyone wants to add to
that, we'll considerate it.
If anyone want to fork
this, please go ahead.
Learn from it and improve.
ALAN POOLE: Absolutely.
And if anyone's
developing in C#,
this is a good reference case
for how you would implement
this OAuth2 or file upload
or Google Maps Engine API
functionality.
DYLAN THOMAS: Great.
Alan, thanks for taking the
time to show this to us.
It's really exciting.
I'm glad we've got the
commercial side of this
and also the open-source
side on the QGIS.
So thanks very much.
And I think that's it
for "What in the World."
We'll see you next time.